hey youtubers what's up so there's gonna
be my Constantine episode 11 video we
also have some details on the
live-action Teen Titan series so I'll
explain what that is at the end of this
always fun seeing Jeremy Davies again
he's probably one of the best guest
actors to ever come on the show casting
him was one of the best decisions they
made he fits so well into this trippy
supernatural world it's also kind of
funny when you think about it in a lost
context like yeah that wasn't really an
alternate dimension but it's pretty
similar to what happened in this episode
so here we go just careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it
yet starting with top five moments
number five the book of Jacob Shaw
chanson a character from the DC Universe
that there is a Marvel character named
Jacob Shaw he's a really minor person
just related to the Sebastian Shaw
Hellfire Club character but there are
tons of magical books in the DC
continuity most notably the book of
destiny that's a book that contains the
past present and future there's the book
of eternity that's a Jack Kirby creation
it's a spell book that contains the
story of existence which supposedly
gives whoever holds the book incredible
powers
then there's the Necronomicon that's
supposedly the ultimate book of magic
it's where Felix Faust gets his power
from the transportation scene at the
beginning reminded me of the the
Hellraiser movies whenever someone opens
the tesseract like it it transports them
to this freaky alternate dimension of
torture and pain anytime you wake up
next to a freaky meathook you know it's
not gonna end well if you didn't
recognize him William Mapother is Jacob
Shaw just society stir egg he's actually
Tom Cruise's real-life brother Tom
Cruise's real last name is maple there
he just changed it whenever he became an
actor in the context of the show his
original experiments were in trying to
achieve the singularity merging mine
with machine moving on to number four
Ritchie's explanation of samsara and
transcendence this is all just a prelude
to Ritchie's story in the comics if you
ever saw that Johnny Depp movie
transcendence is it's the same idea the
mind of a human uploaded to computers
transcending physical form it's meant to
be a backdoor to immortality that's
usually why most people are trying to
achieve the singularity so that they can
live forever
I actually I really like the argument
that Constantine had with them
Constantine says you can't liberate
yourself from samsara the cycle of life
and death until you fulfill your life's
purpose and Ricci argues that libera
is the purpose of life I could totally
imagine two people getting like super
stoned and trying to argue both sides of
this and getting nowhere moving on to
number three Richie's data mining and
the inside of his office if you gaze
into the chaos long enough it can
swallow you whole
that line is the second big reference to
his comic book arc Richie's offices is
full of all kinds of awesome things too
if you just look around the background
there's the mucous membrane album that
was the punk band that he was in with
Constantine in the comics then just look
at the titles of some of the books on
his shelf here this is just fun
elephants on acid what the hell is that
there's even this Swamp Thing Easter Egg
here so it's actually a reference to
Alec Holland it's just a note you know
sent to Alec Holland the bummer is is
the Constantine showrunners confirmed
they have no plans to bring swampthing
on he explained that it's just because
of the complicated process of clearing
characters with DC and the lack of a
compelling reason to use them in the
narrative so one thing is just something
that they didn't plan to do in season 1
season 2 though that's a whole other
story based on the way they talked about
it I think that they are open to doing
Swamp Thing in season 2 if they do get a
season 2 later when they go back to his
office and it's it's nighttime you
actually see the Richie painting that's
actually what he looks like in the comic
books number 2 Constantine and Richie in
the cemetery I like the way that this
started out Constantine walking past
that big quote so what this is is it's
from Song of Solomon 2:17 in the King
James Bible it's all about the darkness
coming before the dawn is just
foreshadowing for the resurrection
crusade in the rising darkness the full
quote the full quote from the Bible
reads until the day shall break and
shadows flee away turn my beloved and be
thou a row or a young heart upon the
mountains of bether
then later in the episode we actually we
see him in the tomb standing between the
image of light and darkness which i
think is totally appropriate for the
character and totally funny all the DC
TV shows in general have really good
cinematography but I feel like
Constantine and Gotham pay extra special
attention to the way they frame
characters so when you see the next
episode just look where characters are
standing just pay close attention to
what's in the background behind their
heads if you're like a TV show that
doesn't have millions and millions of
dollars to spend on CG explosions or
crazy effects really trippy
cinematography is a way to make up for
that just a way to make things look
really cool
and my number one moment Ritchie and
Konstantin hack Shahs world Ritchie goes
totally neo matrix in here I was
actually surprised by the way they ended
things just because of the way Ritchie
story ended in the comics what ends up
happening is Ritchie does achieve
singularity just like they did in the
episode only he stays there like his
mind has permanently left there I think
the reason that they did it this way
that they let him come back is because
they want to be able to use Jeremy
Davies in a future episode they're just
betting on season two it's just like
doing Jim Corrigan and not letting him
turn into the spectre till a future
season one of the changes from the
comics is that is that Ricci achieves
the singularity while hacking the
resurrection crusade that group that Zed
tried to escape from I don't know that
Jeremy Davies is gonna be in the finale
I do know that Jim Corrigan is gonna be
in it but they might weaves together
some of these comic book storylines and
provide up a fairly satisfying
conclusion in case they don't get a
season 2 here's my big question for you
guys what was your favorite moment from
the episode and of all the guest stars
how do you think that Jeremy Davies
stacks up I mean do you like Felix Faust
better
do you like Jeremy Davies as Richie or
do you like Jim Corrigan the best
they've had some really good guest
starts this season I would say you know
between Jim Corrigan and Richie Simpson
Jeremy Davies here those are my two
favorites so far although Felix Faust is
a pretty big deal here's a couple of the
Easter eggs that I haven't mentioned
already so when Richie says their cancer
to other people Constantine standing
there smoking a cigarette
that's just another subtle reference to
the dangerous habits storyline in the
comics that's the one where Constantine
has this super advanced form of lung
cancer
the bradstreet Hall sign that's really
clearly shown in frame here that's a
reference to Tim Bradstreet the comic
book artist he's known for doing a lot
of Hellblazer cover art and then when
Richie says the only rule there is
Shaw's God and Constantine says he won't
be the first one I dealt with what he
means is is that he has dealt directly
with the God and the devil of the DC
Universe he is this Bluff ability that
allows him to successfully live to God
in the devil it's just part of his
genetic heritage the order magic that
his family descends from I think my only
significant thumbs down from the episode
were the the girl getting trapped in the
alternate dimension by looking at her
cell phone screen that felt like a bit
of a derp I didn't like the student
actors in general their performances but
there's no way that they're going to be
able to hold
meantime with Jeremy Davies sometimes
that happens where you have episodes
where you get really amazing actors
paired with actors that are that's a
great William Mapother was funny as the
crazy psychopath I felt like a couple of
his scenes dragged on like where they
did the scientific method scene where he
was like well you have to test it you
have to chop me up with the ax to see if
this is real I felt like that was a
little long they could have just sped
right through that I think the only time
I enjoyed them letting scenes drag on
where whenever Jeremy Davies was being
crazy he just does it so well it's so
compelling if you guys really want to
see him be crazy just go back and watch
his lost episodes okay
so I promise Teen Titans news so there's
a live-action Teen Titans show if you
guys didn't know about it it's
definitely coming it's gonna be on TNT
they haven't officially announced a lot
of things but supposedly the list of
characters are gonna use has leaked out
we know there's gonna be Nightwing
Starfire and Raven you want to say those
characters names they're gonna be doing
the arrow thing where they use their
real-life names or their alter egos so
it'll be a Dick Grayson Rachel Roth is
gonna be the Raven dark home alter-ego
the new rumors though are that they're
gonna have Hawk and Dove
it'll be Hank Hall and dawn Granger and
Barbara Gordon as Oracle which I know is
a bummer because I really want Felicity
Smoak to be the only Oracle type
character in the DC Universe right now
but Barbara Gordon is a total badass so
we can't say no to her because they're
calling her Oracle they haven't said
anything about whether or not she's
gonna be in a wheelchair though the only
ones that have been confirmed the only
confirmed characters are Nightwing Raven
and Starfire no word on when it's gonna
premiere how many episodes are gonna be
I definitely think there will be some
news by the time we get to Comic Con
though I'll totally do more videos when
we get more information about it in
related news new episode of Gotham
tonight so be sure to subscribe to get
that I'll post the video rat to the
episode airs and big stuff happening on
arrow in the flash so be sure to catch
up on that right now you can click here
to catch up on all my Constantine videos
and click here to catch up on Gotham
before tonight thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five I'll see
you guys in just a little bit
you